oh my God I cannot do a pull-up
sometimes it's really hard to find time
to work out but Decades of research
shows that the stress the exercise puts
on the body actually trains it to fend
off major chronic conditions like
diabetes cancer obesity and heart
disease here we go this is so hard and
it increases our ability to be
independent as we age but let's fact
check that go go go you got it I took
two clinical stress oh my God and of
course did lots and lots of exercise the
goal was to see how much I could improve
by chances of longevity with some pretty
intense workouts it's not fun it is so
hot out here let's see how it goes
Heather Milton is a clinical exercise
physiologist at the NYU langone Sports
reforming Center and for this experiment
my longevity trainer so we're doing the
stressor of the exercise but then
allowing you the adaptation process and
the lower heart rate in between which
essentially suppresses stressors this
first test is going to give us our
Baseline for my longevity related
metrics first we track my heart rate
recovery or how quickly my heart rate
came down from its peak for that we used
a simple heart rate monitor the other
metric is VO2 max which is the maximum
rate at which your heart lungs and
muscles use oxygen that was measured
with this sensor that ingested the era
was breathing into the tubed mask this
is going to be tighter oxygen
consumption should be low for light
walking because that shouldn't really
take that much effort every 30 seconds
or so the treadmill got faster and
steeper during the test and my oxygen
consumption went up give it to all where
are you now
all right almost there almost after
running for about nine minutes I had to
stop my heart rate peaked at 167 beats
per minute stay on the treadmill it's
gonna come down I'm gonna watch that
heart rate response you currently
already have a nice BO2 so I want to see
that it's above 26. yours was 38.6
that's equal to the milliliters of
oxygen consumed per kilogram of your
weight each minute my heart rate
recovery was only seven beats per minute
ideally it'd be at least 12. recovery is
really important because that's when
we're allowing our body to process all
the stressors that we put in and then
make the adaptations to become bigger
faster stronger I want to test number
two I did a series of heavier and
heavier leg presses press press press
press
there you go I maxed out a 205 pounds
that gave us a sense of my muscle and
joint strength which directly relates to
having good balance and having good
balance helps avoid Falls one of the
biggest factors for preventable deaths
as we age so with all that info Heather
put together this 10 day fitness plan
for me focusing on cardio and strength
training I expected a challenge into
sweat that was hard but even on this
short 10-day fitness plan I still ran
into a few issues the weights I have are
not optimal
I want to see the video my GoPro
overheated 86 degree beads I'm not going
to go outside because the air quality is
terrible out there I probably should
have picked a better time to make this
video like when I wasn't traveling for
work you want to welcome you to Miami
but I think that's the reality for most
people we squeeze in a workout whenever
we can and I'm done tomorrow I go back
to NYU for my final stress test
hopefully all that hard work over the
last 10 days has paid off all right
ready to go
you're in control you tell me when you
absolutely reach that Max otherwise keep
going you got this everything looks
great
my VO2 max didn't change as expected
Heather says improvements in VO2 max
take at least six to eight weeks it
requires a lot of complex cardiovascular
changes so things like heart tissue
getting stronger lungs taking in more
oxygen blood vessels becoming more
elastic and new healthier red blood
cells that deliver oxygen to muscles we
did see other related improvements we
were able to do a minute more which
means you're able to achieve more work
in a faster Pace without getting to your
maximal insertion and that meant my body
got more efficient at using oxygen the
higher Fitness level is the lower the
effort level is or the lower the ask for
your body for those General tasks simple
things like walking around working
putting away groceries and cleaning your
heart rate recovery was much better too
mine went from 7 to 21 beats per minute
I was a little less confident though
about the leg press because for most of
the experiment I mean I didn't have
weights right I had my two laptops and
children I can only do five bucks a year
the first one felt like feathers
that's a good sign we started at 65
pounds and went up from there I finished
the test at 245 pounds 40 pounds higher
than before I guess hard work pays off
strength training is also important for
improving insulin sensitivity and
maintaining healthy blood glucose levels
that can Stave off some of those big
Killers I mentioned earlier things like
diabetes and obesity scientists don't
yet know what the optimal amount of
exercise for each person is but
generally they recommend 150 minutes of
moderate exercise per week a 10-year
study of 650 000 adults showed that
those who got at least 75 minutes of
exercise lived 1.8 years longer than
inactive adults people who worked out
five to eight hours a week lived more
than four years longer so I was in that
range there's no way to say how many
years my 10 days of intense workouts
added to my life but according to this
study a sedentary people age they did
from being self-sufficient to dependent
much sooner than active people so if I
keep up with my workouts I can increase
the time I'm healthy and independent by
more than a decade so what can you do if
you want to start working out towards a
healthier longer life but don't have
access to fancy trainers and tests
wearables are a good place to start they
can track metrics like VO2 max heart
rate recovery and walking steadiness
pretty accurately Heather said that your
heart rate data is the easiest way to go
your resting heart rate should become
lower as your Fitness level improves
exercise is generally good for your
health but too much can also be
counterproductive for me the hardest
part was just getting off the couch so
now that I'm not getting paid to work
out it is harder so good luck out there